To successfully compete in a growing
market, dairy farms are focused on
production efficiency, a significant goal
of which is digital technology. One
farm that has successfully implemented
digital technology is located in the
Almaty region of southern Kazakhstan and has been
operating since 2002. Digitalization
arrived here only 11 years after its
launch.
Humans are not needed there. The operator only
enters to ensure that the cow enters, and the
rest is
done by a robot. The milking process itself is handled by a robot. The total number of
head of milk is 2,020, of which 600 are dairy cows. The
farm produces 20 tons of milk per day, or
about 33 liters per cow. To
service such a herd in the old-fashioned way, a
large staff would be required: technicians,
veterinarians, milkmaids, and cleaners. Today, the
main work is done by equipment. The
cow on the farm is surrounded by
automated systems: water
is supplied in an automatic drinker, manure is removed by a
scraper unit, and combs are activated by
touch. In addition, the animal
is constantly under constant
computer surveillance. The
cows have collars on their legs and
motion sensors that simplify the work.  The
work of veterinarians
turns out to be such a reason: we learn that a
cow is walking, and the assemblator looks at the
computer and can find out that the cow is
walking and can be inseminated. All data on
each animal in the herd is collected and
analyzed in the herd management program. The
company's management has already felt the
benefits of introducing digital technologies:
saving time and money. This can be
seen in the example of feeding.
When a cow approaches the robot,
separate feed is given to her, and it turns out that for each
cow this is individual. For example, if
this person were to give, he would not know.
For example, how much feed to give this cow,
since he does not know how much she is
milking at the moment, and it turns out that the
robot completely calculates this and
gives her what she gives milk for, that is what they
give her feed for. It turns out that if, for example, a
cow is given
45-50 liters, yes, the amount of
this feed should be two kilograms,
if a little less, it turns out to be one and a half
kilograms, thereby we benefit from
not wasting feed just like that
[music] on the
opposite side of Kazakhstan in the
northern Kazakhstan region since 2019,
similar technologies have been introduced  Another
dairy farm
before approaching
We traveled from Kazakhstan
[music]
We decided to build a modern
automated garden management system
on a dairy farm in many ways similar
to another example, it also tracks
all the herd indicators and controls, in
particular, feeding, women make up
almost half of the farm workers play an
important role in managing the system and
programs.
This is all the information after feeding,
it is transmitted via Wi-Fi to the main
computer here I can already look at the
reports,
say for today or for
yesterday, the
data for each animal is stored in
digital form, specialists know how much
milk each cow produces and what
she eats, this information is especially
useful when making a decision about the fall,
we have such a report on nesterus,
these are the cows that have not been inseminated,
although they should have already been inseminated,
there are, let's say, those cows that
have calved, she is already
74 days old, she should have been inseminated a long time ago,
but she has not yet come into heat,
that is, she either needs to be put on treatment
or she needs to be looked at
[music]
at this dairy commodity company, they also
appreciated the economic advantages of
digital technologies, which are expressed in  There are no
savings in staff time,
consumables, wages,
expenses, family expenses for effective
insemination, that's more and more, there are
fewer overruns in our herd,
and this accordingly affects the
lactation period, the lactation period, and accordingly, the
economy as a whole, and so on,
for dairy farmers to
achieve success in today's world.
That is why successful dairy farmers
closely monitor the emergence of
[music]
[applause]